so you left LA and you're back in
Washington what was the impetus for that
moving to Washington mm-hmm
I just needed a new new scene you know
needed some more green I kind of liked
the rain I'm going to do like beautiful
rain down on me there you go Oh fan yeah
but at what point because everybody
talks about going somewhere else but a
lot of people don't do it
what was it where you just said it's
time and FA IIIi want to change the
course in my life well one of the pieces
was I was young and probably twenty four
or five so when were younger we have
more flexibility I think in our choices
and in our lifestyles and things like
that so one of the things that I try to
get across to my college students I
teach song writing and recording to
college students which other oh that's a
job or you kidding me I love it but I
try to get them to understand the power
and flexibility of their youth because
they don't really know it because they
haven't been 15 years older yet right
they haven't been in the workforce and
running around they're just getting out
of school or in school um so that was a
piece of it being young and not you know
I knew where it's sort of where I wanted
to go with my life but it just seemed
like it seemed like good place yeah
another thing that I say a lot in these
interviews but I'm gonna say it again
is that when you're 20 24 people give
you Pat's on the back and they give you
add a girl at a boy you can do it when
you're 40 they don't do that and
sometimes I think it's because there's
part of them that wants to do it and
they can't and then that's all very real
thing in the adult world you have
certain rules and obligations and so
then you don't get as many added girls
that's true
maybe you can't drop everything and move
to a different city but you always can
do something and that is the key right a
huge difference and you know you got to
pay the rent whatever the deal is okay I
get that you know of course but if you
if you want to be a screenwriter spend a
half an hour a day or two hours on a
Saturday or whatever it is a little bit
of time and you you absolutely can do
that it's just about prioritizing right
are you watching TV or are you writing
on your screenplay right I mean let's
get real going back to the image in the
beginning of your book yeah are you
going to the bar or you practicing
guitar right so I mean there's a million
ways to go there's a million things that
you probably don't need in your life you
have to play video games for two hours a
day mm-hmm probably not you know you can
do something productive with that if you
choose right what about that being a
lonelier way because going to the bar
there's also 20 other people that can be
part of what then this isn't my quota
ain't it awful Club it's from Peter
McWilliams you know book and and and he
said there's one in every workplace
there's one in every bar and and it's
great you can commiserate you can talk
we know politics as a hot-button right
now but you go back home and you write
that screenplay it's pretty much just
you it's lonely it is lonely
life is lonely right but it's yours to
choose so if you wanna if you want to be
in that Club go ahead but don't to
me about it right or yourself because we
all have power right and perhaps it is
lonely writing by yourself but guess
what there's a million writing clubs out
there writing meetups and things like
that so join one of those that's true
and suddenly you're all writing by
yourself but at least you at the same
table right I mean I've done that a
million times is that why you're writing
coffee shops or maybe you don't I'm just
assuming I do sometimes sometimes
not yeah I mean that's that's why half
the people go to coffee shop in Seattle
you will see 40 people in a room four or
five of them are talking to each other
and everybody else is on the computer
doing something why do they do that
because they want to be together even
though they're separate and I mean I'm
not saying it's the greatest thing in
the world we do it together
you know I kind of want to be together
but it's it's something
you